un momento para la actualidad económica
para ello nos acompaña danielle hablando
de darle la bienvenida comenzamos
hablando de los grandes bancos del mundo
que se preparan para el retorno a
presencia de sus empleados o la marina
muy buenas noches pues después de más de
un año de teletrabajo los principales
bancos del mundo comienzan a pensar en
el retorno de sus empleados a las
oficinas el financial times hizo un
análisis con 20 de ellos y descubrió que
unos están más rezagados que otros en
sus planes por ejemplo el hsbc ni
siquiera ha fijado fecha para el regreso
pero sí se sabe que planea adoptar un
enfoque más flexible de trabajo
presencial colman sachs ofreció comida
gratis a su personal y organizó
conciertos para levantarles la moral en
su regreso a la oficina de este mes
jaypee morgan busca que su personal
vuelva al ruedo en julio tanto en
londres como en nueva york' de bank of
america y morgan stanley esperarán hasta
septiembre y otro grande wall street'
citigroup dijo que adoptará un modelo
híbrido quiere decir que al menos tres
días van a estar en la oficina y el
resto en la casa pero una de las
conclusiones marinas
para el estudio es que los banqueros
quieren que el regreso sea más rápido de
lo que quieren sus empleados y varios de
ellos han sido muy criticados por hacer
este retorno obligatorio y no opcional
es que volver a la oficina al final se
hace del siglo después declaró después
de tantos meses trabajando desde casa
pasamos a hora argentina donde la
inflación en mayo cedió un poco pero
sigue al alta bueno los precios de la
canasta familiar aumentaron 3,3 por
ciento en mayo frente al mes anterior y
venían de crecer 48 % en abril esa es la
buena noticia la mala es que si se
comparan esos precios con los de un año
atrás la diferencia desde el 48 8% y en
alimentos el aumento fue incluso mayor
pues los precios estuvieron muy cerca de
crecer un 50 por ciento la situación más
preocupante es la de los cárnicos que
hoy cuestan el 72 9% más que hace un año
en mayo pasado el gobierno suspendió las
exportaciones de carne vacuna
precisamente para controlarlos pero
parece que esta estrategia no está
funcionando y vamos ahora a
centroamérica donde en honduras
aprobaron un aumento de salarios bueno
éste fue el acuerdo al que
llegaron la empresa privada y los
trabajadores de ese país centroamericano
con la mediación del gobierno su
vigencia será retroactiva a partir del
primero de junio el ministerio de
trabajo explicó que el incremento
dependerá del número de trabajadores que
tenga la empresa si tiene hasta 50 será
del 4,01 por ciento si tiene hasta 150
empleados ganarán un 5% más y si su
planta excede esa cifra el valor subirá
8 por ciento el salario mínimo en
honduras marina es de unos 10 mil
lempiras en moneda local que equivalen
como a unos 417 dólares pues buenas
noticias para los hondureños entonces
vamos ahora a europa donde bruselas dio
luz verde a los planes de recuperación
de españa y de portugal primero
recordemos marina que el año pasado la
unión europea abrió un fondo de
recuperación de 800 mil millones de
euros para repartir entre los países
miembros y que cada uno debe presentar
un plan que diga cómo se van a gastar
esos recursos en el caso de españa la
comisión avaló un plan que irá dirigido
principalmente a apoyar los objetivos
climáticos y la transición digital
escuchamos
por esta aprobación es un hito
importante para el desembolso de
alrededor de 70 mil millones de euros en
los próximos años para ser muy precisos
69 mil 500 millones una vez que el plan
sea aprobado por el consejo estaremos
listos para desembolsar los primeros
fondos en julio pero españa no es el
único la comisión también le dio luz
verde al plan de recuperación portugués
por 16 mil 600 millones de euros ahora
la decisión se somete a ratificación por
parte de los estados miembros tenemos
pendientes vamos ahora con indicadores
de la jornada no wall street recibió de
manera negativa los anuncios de la
reserva federal muy esperados según los
cuales podría subir las tasas de interés
en 2023 o sea antes de lo que pensaba
europa cerró mixto aunque el índice que
reúne a las 600 principales acciones de
ese continente marcó récord histórico y
en américa latina hubo más caídas que
subidas siguiendo la tendencia por
supuesto de nueva york' y cuál es la
cifra del día de hoy de 16 de junio es
malita mil millones de libras esterlinas
que perdieron en conjunto los clubes de
la premier league inglesa la temporada
pasada
esta es la peor pérdida colectiva en la
historia del torneo según un análisis
del financial times los que más
perdieron
everton y manchester city bueno pues
muchas gracias daniela por la
información económica y otras gracias
sigan con más información en nuestra
página web france24 puntocom
[Música]